that's an interesting question a lot of
it is how someone to mostly places like
the SEC erful lawyer so you'd have to
know how to design a culture which
empowers lawyers to do the right thing
and I haven't run law firms I only I
know what doesn't work and this may not
be the perfect answer your question I
know it doesn't work I'll give you an
example of what doesn't work and then
I'll maybe I'll help me think of what
does I remember calling the SEC which
not only regulates publicly traded
companies but also in effect mutual
funds and investment companies and I had
the the private thesis that you know a
couple of years after I left Enron that
Enron in fact was masquerading as an
operating company it really was there's
a lack of controlled assets really a
closed-end a mutual fund and I wasn't
gonna mention that name is but I just
wanted to know how as you see looked at
these so I finally got the right guy at
the SEC and actually does come back to
the lawyers they actually and I I said
well how do you know when a company's a
like a real operating company and what
its release looks like an African
operating company really is just a
closed-end mutual fund that tries to
look like it operates things and then he
said I still remember this we rely on
the opinions of high quality law firms
and I said well do you ever check these
assumptions sounds a very fundamental
assumption do you ever try to determine
whether or not that's a reliable
assumption and then he said gee we
really don't know I said oh okay thanks
but so what I would do is is probably be
unafraid of going after big people being
unafraid of losing an occasional case so
I didn't have just a series of
situations where people don't admit
guilt they paid chump change fine and we
go
about their way I would I would try to
determine where the law is in some cases
I'm not a lawyer so the fact is maybe
strategically that doesn't make sense
but in terms of being able to empower
the the the attorneys I'd want to make
it clear that we're out there to enforce
the law and as a letter and spirit and
we're going to we're going to make sure
people oh there's a new marshal in town
and and we're gonna go after some people
to think they're immune and that have
really big-time law firms defending them
and see if we can put the fear of God
and some of these people know that's
that's what I would try to do